foreign
was in the hospital 42 days my sister 35
and uh my sister passed first
she's six days later my mom passed I
don't know that I've breathed it at all
I've been sad I've cried more times than
I could possibly count
[Music]
what's up this is John with the Dr John
deloney show
the greatest show you can possibly be
listening to there's a billion and a
half podcasts and this is the best use
of your time it's the greatest mental
health in marriage and parenting podcast
that has ever existed and I'm so glad
that you're with us
um and I'm just taking a cue from
politics and if I just keep saying it it
becomes true all of a sudden I like I
like
uh what's the thing to say nowadays it's
my truth right as though that's a thing
it's my truth hey um if you want to be
on the show give me a buzz
1-844-693-3291 and give me a call leave
a message and Jenna will give you a call
back and we'll talk through what's going
on in your life and we'll have you on
the show can't wait or you go to John
deloney.com ask and thank you thank you
thank you the five star reviews are
starting to pour in in fact the guy here
at Ramsey Solutions where I work who's
over podcast said what happened we just
got an onslaught of reviews and
subscribers so thank you so much this
just sends the show out to so many other
people
um so they can get the help they need
you know they may not even get help they
just you know
it's just good to feel like you're not
the only one going through some of this
stuff right you're you're not crazy so
thank you so much for the reviews please
just hit the Subscribe button it's very
very simple and it really helps us out
um hey this is Super Rad Kelly handed me
this
um
came out a few weeks ago a few weeks ago
the the headline is lonely 67 year old
sets up woodworking shed to combat
loneliness in men following a global
Trend says across the English-speaking
World men are learning that the easiest
way to cure about a social isolation is
not by talking face to face but shoulder
to shoulder Philip Jackson moved back to
England from Australia he was 67 and
felt like a stray dog in his native town
and so he got a shed
and started um inviting men and women uh
over to do woodworking together
it's about plugging into the social
fabric of a community whether it's
through meeting up for coffee building a
park bench or listening to to the
problems someone is going through in
their marriage
it's a break from people's weekly
routines in 2005 there's an estimated
200 men sheds operating in Australia and
today there's a membership base of over
twelve hundred one thousand two hundred
men's sheds and uh you can
even the ministry for health and aged
care have started offering 10 grand for
people and this is in Australia to kick
these things up and get them going
um there are 17 U.S men's sheds way to
go America including one in Hawaii let's
let's get more of these up
um I was just talking to my friend gwain
we're gonna start playing Guitar
together here up at the office in fact I
even traded
um an old gun for a guitar case how's
that for Liberal propaganda I trade a
gun for an old guitar I mean for not a
guitar case for an old amplifier a small
one that I can bring up here and leave
at the office and me and my buddies are
going to start jamming up here I figure
I've played for about 35 years I should
be better anyway so I'm gonna start
taking lessons I'm Gonna Learn and it's
just gonna be some guys hanging out
playing guitar together which is going
to be good for us it's going to be good
for our our families it's gonna be good
for our communities
um here's the deal it's not really a
Woodworking Shop Jackson says it's a
community Enterprise where people with
problems can come and discuss them with
friends
um for Americans who feel a woodworking
support group would be welcome in their
community the U.S men's shed Association
there's an association for everybody
the U.S men's shed Association sounds
like a Garth Brooks song has plenty of
resources for those looking to start
their own shed including a step-by-step
process for getting a 501 C3 non-profit
status applying for Grants from health
care and other funding sources to launch
a program even ideas for your first
meeting here's the deal do something
do something when people ask me
um hey how do I make friends how do I
get connected go first go first
go first and you know what's going to
happen there's gonna be some weirdos
that show up there for sure are and some
folks with crazy problems and you have
to say I don't I don't know what you're
talking about you need to go see a
counselor
um hey will you pass the miter saw
please like it's a matter of just
getting and Community together because
there's going to be a group of people
that you connect with that end up
becoming a rider dies if you will just
go first so good good on this guy good
on this guy and good to the 17 folks in
America who've started up these men
sheds and I hope to see a whole whole
bunch more
um local YMCAs local churches local
community leaders let's get it going
just I don't care what the group is
let's just start getting people together
and finding things we can do uh with one
another all right let's go to Kristen in
man we have been living in Seattle
lately man home of the grunge movement
what's up Kristen how we doing good how
are you good are you just thinking about
Pearl Jam and Nirvana this morning is
that what you do in Seattle when you
wake up just I don't know no I I'm not
the typical Seattle person for you
that's my favorite answer of the day are
you just waking up thinking of Pearl Jam
and Nirvana and you just go no no no no
I I do have to say I love the men shed
thing I I think there is something to
say about creating a space where people
can do things while they open up and
talk because I think it's so it's not
intimidating and I think more of that
needs to be happening I agree there's
something about
um doing something with somebody that
makes it easier to have a conversation
than it does just putting your hands in
your lap and staring at somebody inside
it and then saying tell me what's wrong
with your life and on that note Kristen
tell me what's wrong with your life
all right what's up no that's okay
um I have I have three teenagers
um ages 13 16 and 18.
and my question is um I'm also I've been
divorced for five years and so I
understand my kids are best served if
they have healthy relationships with
both their dad and myself
so how do I support and facilitate if I
am able to them having a positive
relationship with their dad
while at the same time helping them
understand what healthy relationship
boundaries look like when he's probably
not a healthy relationship and he's
making choices that don't create a
healthy relationship
yeah
you just said that in the most
eloquently evasive way I've heard in a
long time look you were very gifted at
that
um like I could get off the phone now
and feel really good and if someone's
like what did she say I would go I don't
know but it just sounded so nice so
let's get to the nitty-gritty
um here's what I think I heard
you got divorced five years ago and I'm
just gonna throw it out there you may
say you're an idiot you still aren't a
super fan of the divorce and your
husband is not being the dad that you
envisioned him being as a co-parent and
your kids are
struggling
okay I
I am broken-hearted every single day
that I wrote a chapter of my kid's life
for them that they are now stuck with
um
and I think he is doing a terrible job
of parenting yeah there we go thank you
that's thank you for speaking English
that now I'm talking he sucks right
all right um and I'm I'm doing my best I
have
um I've encouraged them to have
conversations with him to identify the
problem help him figure out like can
they're missing out on quality time he
doesn't make time for them so can you
suggest can we go for a walk Dad can we
go for ice cream can we have a movie
night I've met with his new wife we've
had a conversation I've met with a
pastor in the church that he respects
about how to encourage a healthy
relationship with his kids there's
nothing I've done that it's helped him
make changes he needs to have good
relationships with his kids and I don't
know how to handle it as a supportive
co-parent on my behalf you have to open
up your hands and let that go
because that's your family that's your
fantasy not his
and I hate that for you Mike there's
there's there's nothing you can do
he is making a choice to not be involved
in this kid's life and that's going to
be his cross to carry for a long long
time
um you mentioned at the very beginning
to call the best thing for them you're
exactly right is two adults who lean in
and love their kids
um
your kids aren't going to get the best
and it's making peace with that
you you waking up every day and choosing
to live brokenhearted is adding more
bricks to their backpacks that they
don't need to carry
why do you you regret this you say you
don't regret it I disagree with you what
what is the baggage you're still
carrying do you wish y'all had worked it
out do you wish you'd stuck it out like
what are you hanging on to or you just
wish that you hadn't put your like what
what is it that you're upset with
yourself over
why doesn't marriage for 17 years it was
very lonely there was never any
emotional intimacy there was never a
friendship it was very much me raising
four kids on my own basically being a
single parent in that marriage
I do not regret leaving the relationship
I regret the heartache a divorced home
creates for my kids
did you also regret the heartache that a
lonely isolated
spouse create
did you also Lament The Heart the
heartache that your kids are gonna have
to carry watching their dad act like a
grown-up child and forcing mom into a
parental role instead of a partnership
role like
you you made a choice a relational
choice because you couldn't survive
anymore
and yes that choice comes with
consequences no no mistaking that
but choosing something else would have
come with consequences potentially more
extreme ones
because your kids would have grown up in
a home so filled with tension and so
filled with angst and so filled with
rage that they would have spent all of
their time wondering what was wrong with
him because they felt insane at least
now they have something to point at
right
yeah and they've got a mom that loves
them like crazy Fair
absolutely and so the story of their dad
is unfolding in front of them
and we don't want this you don't I mean
this isn't something you would cheer for
or hope for
right but there will come a moment when
your kids if they haven't already go oh
okay
oh they're there okay right and here's
where that's dangerous for a kid
is you've probably heard me say this
before but they know that half of them
is that guy
and what if that turns out to be me what
is so bad about me why would my dad
choose fill in the blank other than
their kid like they're searching for
answers that have logical conclusion I
mean there's they're asking questions
that have logical answers and they're
not being met with logical responses and
it's just unnerving and the best you can
do is love them like crazy
and we we talk about that a lot because
I've heard you say that quite often and
especially my 18 year old he doesn't see
his dad and he doesn't talk to his dad
anymore and he has said multiple times
I never want to be like him or I'm going
to make sticky notes and put him up on
my bathroom mirror when I have my own
place it says do not be your dad okay
here's here's where Mom you can really
help out
because what that's telling him is half
of me is dysfunctional and broken
and so I think it's hard but it's
important to say yeah there's some
things that I wish your dad was doing
differently I wish he's got I wish he
got to see what an awesome son you are
like I get to see and
your dad is really Charming in love and
funny and he can be really engaging and
he's got some good qualities too and by
lifting up the good parts of your
ex-husband you're lifting up your son
and that's really hard because it's easy
to just burn the whole guy to the ground
but you're burning your son to the
ground too when that happens
no and and I think it's trying to find
um those few good qualities
um and pointing them out and you know
saying he has a really good work ethic
and he passed that on to you and I see
that in you and so you have got some
really positive things yes yes yes yes
and the things that you might see in
yourself that you don't like that are
like myself or your dad that you take on
simply because it's what you are modeled
you're you're capable of changing those
things too oh dude you're not a prisoner
to what you've been modeled and who your
parents are so good
I I you're in a season of discomfort and
so I almost hesitate to tell you this
but you're doing it exactly right
thank you you're doing exactly right um
you're making the best of a very messy
situation and I would if I'm in your
suit like the best I can tell you is if
I'm sitting in your seat
and my wife had left me and it's five
years later and she's remarried and
moved on with her life and suddenly she
doesn't want anything to do with the
kids
I would open my hands up and not try to
direct her behaviors I'll try to use
that extra energy and love my kids I
would use that extra energy and love
myself enough just make sure I'm well
that I'm taking care of business that
I've got new relationships
um you can't take away your kids
questions about what they did to divide
up the home you can't take away your
kids questions about why their dad
doesn't want to spend time with them
that doesn't make any sense to them
um you can assure them there's not a way
they can act their way into their dad's
heart but right now he's making some
different decisions and it is it is it
stinks
but they're lovely and they're loved and
they're good kids
I would have your kids write your dad
their dad letters maybe make that a
weekly exercise
and what that will do for your kids is
it helps them begin to laser in on what
they miss
it really helps them come up with some
poignant questions and it keeps the
thoughts and feelings and emotions from
overwhelming a 13 or 18 or 16 year old
mind and body and so every week dad
won't talk to him dad doesn't want to
visit with him cool we're going to write
dad a letter and then they're going to
give them to you and you may not send
those letters you may just hang on to
them because this is going to be an
exercise for the home
um it's gonna be an exercise maybe they
read them out loud to you and they will
be heartbreaking
or maybe they're super fun or maybe
they're a mixture of both but it gives
your kids an outlet
it gives their bodies the opportunity to
speak to their dad when their dad just
won't speak to them
so that's just an idea
um maybe it's a once a month thing it
will be a painful exercise but it's an
exercise I think over time will really
benefit
um
and I'll just say this I know this goes
without saying but parents if you get
divorced you get divorced parents do
adults do adult things
show up for your kids
[Music]
show up
for your kids
we'll be right back
[Music]
hey deloney here and I've got a word
from our sponsor from betterhelp I've
been on the giving and receiving end of
therapy for years when I was spinning
out like a decade ago with wild anxiety
I had a moment that light bulb moment
that I knew I had to do something
different I knew I had to change
something probably a lot of some things
right but I found myself without the
tools for taking the next step
and when you're facing problems or
challenges in life it's way too easy to
get stuck in that anxious spiral of Doom
I've been there but when you learn how
to stop that cycle and start taking
ownership of your life that's when
you're free and that's what therapy can
help you do it gives you the tools you
need to do the problem solving in your
own life and that's why I love better
help better help is online therapy that
offers video phone and even live chat
sessions with your therapist it's more
affordable than in-person therapy plus
you can be matched with a therapist in
under 48 hours if you're ready to get
the tools that you need to deal with the
curveballs life's thrown at you therapy
can help visit betterhelp.com deloni to
get 10 off your first month that's
betterhelp.com deloney
all right we're back let's go to Andrew
in Dayton Ohio what's up Andrew
hey what's going on Dr John how are you
sir party my brother what's up
oh
uh here's I'm just gonna cut to it how
do I grieve
well that's a that's an open-ended broad
question what do you want to grieve
ma'am yeah everything
um
Let's uh
let's go back
um a year ago my mom got sick
and uh
she went in the hospital about six days
later my sister my baby sister got sick
when they get sick okay
and
um my mom was in the hospital
42 days my sister 35
um
and uh my sister passed first
jeez it'll be a year coming up this week
and then
um my sister had special needs so the
she was she was on a respirator and all
the machines that they hook her up to
and basically
um the doctor wouldn't pull her off the
machine that wasn't doing anything but
keeping her heartbeat until we told our
mom
and asked her permission to take her off
the machine even though my mom was
incapacitated
and so we told her because
you know it was the right thing to do
and
um
six days later my mom passed yeah
and and I and I know it was related to
finding out that she'd lost a child
not no doubt in my mind
and so coming up on a year
and I just
I I don't know that I've grieved it at
all yeah yeah I've I've been sad
I've I've I've cried more times than I
could possibly count
I've lost
hours of sleep every night
it's created all sorts of other health
problems which is telling me I'm not
doing something right
no it's not it's not hey it's not it's
not Andrew I I think you have you have
grieved it you are grieving it
this is what grief is
crying at the weirdest moments it's
waking up in the middle of the night
it's throwing up it's feeling sick
it's looking at like if you have like a
whoop strap it's looking at it and like
you're at 25 recovery for four months
it's like your body's
shuts itself off because it can't it
it's so overwhelming
this is grief man and it's awful but but
then how do I how do I work through it
because it's not something
I mean I've lost people before
um hey dude bro not your mom man not
your mom not your special needs sister
that you've been defending since the day
she was born
like you had a purpose
and your purpose was your sister
and in 30 days it went away
and you've got your mom dude that's a
whole other level that's not like losing
a friend or losing a buddy or losing a
grandparent that's your mother
I've sat with people who are 63 years
old who lose their 80 something year old
parents and they just unspool because
it's their mom
it's their dad you know what I mean this
is different and you're coming up on an
anniversary moment and for whatever
reason I I don't know the physiology of
it or the biology of it but I know that
anniversary markers
our bodies tend to just ramp it up
they just turn the heat up on us and
things get a little bit sharper a little
bit low or a little bit darker
and in your case we're ending we're
heading off into the winter season so
things are getting grayer and colder and
it just all works together to say screw
the world right
yeah and can I be honest um for those
listening I don't want to hear any of
your political nonsense I got a friend
who's hurting here
um but when you lose your mom and your
sister
and then a politician gets up and says
this never counted this wasn't ever real
or it's all over now yeah
you're still holding you know you can
look over and see your sister's jacket
hanging on the hook
or when your buddies roll their eyes and
the next politician gets up and it's
like I'm running for office and say this
stupid it's like well I lost my mom and
I lost my city you know I mean so
there's an extra I'm hearing across the
country
especially with coveted losses there's
an extra dose of
hurt on top of it if that makes sense
yeah because it's because my mom like
it's the story of my mom it's the story
of my sister and suddenly it's turned
into a caricature or a drama or a
political move just my mom yeah right
and so there's all sorts of stuff on top
of this
um
here's the best way I can the best
picture I've seen of grief
when your mom passed away and your
sister passed away they cast a long
Shadow over you
when you're sitting in that shadow and
you can see it laid out as though you're
standing in the shadow of a large tree
okay
that shadow length and size will always
be that that big
you lost your mom what you can't see now
is that you will continue to grow
and in one year five years ten years 15
years you will be so far out beyond that
shadow the Shadow's still the same size
but you will have developed and grown
and created a new life there will be
Seasons when you find yourself knocked
down sitting up against that tree in
that shadow and it cast Over You Again
and that might be on the five year
anniversary or the 10-year anniversary
you hear a song or you see a special
needs kid that reminds you of your
little sister and your body just Yanks
you back into it it's cool man
it's cool but what you can't see on this
side of it is your growth
I would tell you not to fight it right
now man you're a year in
I would spend here here let me just say
what I would do if I was used is that a
fair way to approach this
absolutely
um
I would sit down and write Mom a letter
and I would sit down and write sister a
letter
and if you're really Brave I'd find some
way to read those letters too whether if
you have a sister a sibling or you're
married or something like that I would
read that out loud and in that letter
there's usually three parts one of them
is how pissed off I am that you left me
how mad I am that you're gone
whether that's mad at them Matt mad at
God mad at the doctors mad at whoever
another one is I'm just so sad I miss
you here's what it feels like now that
you're gone
and then the third part of that letter
is
here's what you've missed
I got a new job I got a promotion I'm
letting my hair grow long I've gained 48
pounds right whatever like the Astros
are going to win the World Series again
right that's me casting oh I hope not I
hope not
right so it's it's here's what you've
missed and here's here's why that's
important when we transition to here's
what you've missed
we are slowly teaching our bodies and
our minds that it's happened there's a
period at the end of the sentence
and life is continuing to move
and over time you write letters about
what you've missed how much I miss you
and those letters will get more and more
infrequent
and they'll get shorter
and you'll find yourself laughing again
and then you're going to find yourself
have you already done this where you
find yourself just laughing your butt
off dude like you something so funny and
it's usually super profane like you
wouldn't say in front of your mom but
you're laughing and then you feel guilty
for having joy for laughing yeah yeah
yeah yeah
notice when you feel guilty laughing
notice when you feel guilty after sex
notice when you feel guilty about some
of these pleasurable moments in life
that suddenly you think wait a minute I
shouldn't be having pleasure because I'm
still because they died right and
don't beat yourself up over it but just
notice it and then exhale and say no
I'm allowed to smile my mom would want
me to be having a good time
my sister would want me to smile
you know what I mean yeah
yeah I struggle with the different roles
I have to carry right now
um I'm a husband okay I'm a dad okay
um I've got uh
two other biological sisters and then an
adopted special needs sister okay and
then I've got my dad
and then my mom's mom is still alive so
I feel the burden of responsibility to
help her because that was Mom's role
and
it's
I mean it's just challenging it's it's
overwhelming sometimes
here's and I want to flip the whole
thing over okay
okay
you can only do that type of heavy
lifting if Andrew comes first
foreign
physical health comes first you're
sleeping and you're eating right
you're moving your body you're
exercising a couple times a week
you have some friends that you're
talking to
you get buddies together once a week and
you'll go to throw darts or you go I
don't know build something play guitar
whatever it is but you get a group
together
only then you go to church you go back
you get reconnected with a faith
community whatever that looks like for
you only then
are you reinforced enough to then be the
dad that your kids need and by the way
hopefully you've told your kids how sad
you are
oh absolutely absolutely good don't Rob
them of this moment of watching here's
what a man who loves his daughter feels
and is going through don't take that
from him okay be honest with them
otherwise they're going to feel you're
angst and they're going to feel your
distance and they're going to blame
themselves for it
give give that gift to them to let them
watch
I tell them all the time
um I I got I mean my kids are 12 and 10.
perfect and so they're they're at that
age of understanding and all of the
things that they have to process through
um you know we tried to protect them
when we were in the hospital where they
were in the hospital
um I was driving an hour every day to go
see them and
you know trying to keep keep them from
all of the information and
um we learned afterwards that that was
probably not the best way to do that
sure so here we are so you're doing a
good job of communicating now right
yeah we're we're on it now we we learned
the hard way
and so
can I say something hard man
please I'll say something something good
and then I'll say something hard okay
whenever we lose somebody that we love
especially they were hurting as badly as
your sister and your mom are hurting and
the ventilator passing is is brutal you
saw it firsthand right yeah yeah
one of my jobs when I did crisis
response was if somebody had like let's
say they'd lost a kid
say A kid had died by Suicide and mom
was coming home and she was coming to
the house my job was actually to meet
Mom in the four year of that home or in
the front yard and not let Mom come back
and see the kid
and well here's why
because
here is my standard line that I always
gave and it wasn't a line it was the
truth
you don't want this to be the last
picture of your son or daughter in your
mind
you want that last picture the time
y'all hugged when he left your house
that time at Thanksgiving when you were
throwing marshmallows at each other you
don't want this last picture because it
freeze frames in your mind and here's
what we miss they're not hurting anymore
okay the last time you saw your sister
she was in Hell the last time you saw
your mom you watched her
dissolve like just dissipate in front of
you and listen brother they're not
hurting anymore
okay
and it's making peace with oh yeah
they're finally free
they are free free free
and it's sitting in that for a minute
because right now your body is still
trying to make sure everything's okay
with them on the ventilator they're not
there anymore here's the hard thing my
brother they're gone
and no amount of work or trying to
Cobble together more things to throw on
your shoulders
is going to make their life any more
okay they're gone
yeah and it's been able to open your
hands up and for the first time in a
year drop your shoulders down
tell your sisters I need some help tell
your dad how are you man I can help you
but I can't I can't carry you
see the difference there I do okay
yeah
um
I have my good days of course you do bro
you're not broke hey you are not broken
you're not malfunctioning you're you're
a son who loved his mom and you're a
dope brother Who Loved a sister
that's what you are and that means it
hurts
so how do I handle
so when these moments hit and and uh
being perfectly honest you're the first
person I talked to in a year outside of
close friends okay so I feel like I need
more help than what I'm getting but how
do I handle the
those moments where
I'm wrestling with the regret you know
the the miss Thanksgiving the the time I
blew my mom off to go hang with my
buddies you know whatever the story may
be in those moments come up
and then they're just
crushing sometimes that's right that's
right and so there's there's two ways to
move forward from this number one is
when those thoughts pop into your mind
understand you have a choice
you have a choice to meditate on that
lightning bolt that pops in remember
that time you blew mom off for a text
message
and literally say out loud not doing
that
not doing it at your brain trying to
meditate on the things on the negativity
so that it can prevent hurt in the
future and it doesn't prevent hurt in
the future it's just your brain trying
to do the best it can because it's got a
very primitive operating system on it
that says look bear run from bear watch
out for Bears right yeah and so those
lightning bolts pop into your mind when
you're walking down the street and you
remember that time you snapped at your
special needs sister because she was
driving you crazy
and you go nope
and here's the key here's the second key
you have an immediate thought to replace
that with
a time you and your little sister
laughed so hard you thought you were
gonna both vomit on each other that time
you and your mom got into a donut eating
contest and you saw that nine-year-old
girl come out of her in a weird way
or the time your mom cussed at you and
it just slipped out and you laughed
right let's go to that and here's what
will happen in short order if you will
do that work
because you weren't a bad son you're a
human being
if you will do that work in a shorter
amount of time than you think your body
will change the default setting to every
time you think of them they will be
filled with light and joy not oh my God
they just died
okay okay it is saying nope not doing it
I'm not going to meditate on the
negative I remember that time Mom fill
in the blank did something hilarious or
I'm calling Dad
I'm called that see how he's doing and
here's the other big boy thing you gotta
do
you got to sit down with your wife in
the next 48 hours okay and tell her I
have not been honest with you for a year
I've tried to be tough I've tried to
carry all this I felt a ton of
responsibility and I'm heartbroken
because I miss my sister
and I'm heartbroken because I miss my
mom
and there's going to be moments in the
next six months while I'm healing that
I'm not gonna be able to carry it all
and I'm gonna ask you I may lean over
and say hey I need some help today
and that would be one of the greatest
gifts you give your wife
because she's been feeling insane and
helpless sitting on her own hands the
last year and finally her husband's
gonna say I'm not Superman I'm calling
reality as it is
can I get some help and she's gonna say
God yes I'm ready for you is that fair
that's absolutely Fair because I think
she would she's been the one telling me
to get some help that's right um because
she here's why
feels you not sleeping and she feels you
sitting at the kitchen table four feet
from I mean four inches from her and
four thousand miles away from her
it feels it and she doesn't know how to
bridge that Gap so she's asking you to
walk across it and if you sat down and
had that moment of vulnerability tonight
cancel whatever plans you got tonight
and take her out to dinner and just say
I haven't been honest with you I've been
trying to carry all this myself and I'm
sorry
I need some I need you to pick up some
slack for a season
oh my gosh what a gift that would be for
your home my brother what a gift
um
I'll say it one more time you're not
broken man
you're just in it
um do sit down and write your mom that
letter do sit down and write your sister
that letter read it to your wife if you
can read it to your sisters if you can
have them write letters and y'all can
get together for the one year
anniversary of their passing and have
another
celebration slash day of morning
let your kids hear those letters bring
people into this
and you're great you will begin to grow
and stand Beyond this Shadow that's my
promise my brother hang on the line I'm
going to send you a copy of own your
past change your future you've you've
been through it and now we're gonna ask
ourselves what do we do next and I got
you thanks for calling my brother we'll
be right back
hey guys deloney here and I've got a
word from our sponsor whoop if you've
listened to the show for any length of
time you know I'm a major nerd about
Fitness sleep mental health and building
healthier life habits and let's just say
this whoop makes my nerd heart so happy
one reason I love whoop is that it's not
like all the other fitness trackers that
mix in a watch in laser lights and
smiley faces and a million notifications
and reminders that you you need to get
your steps in no whoop is a fitness
wearable that actually looks cool and
it's comfortable and it gives you data
that really matters it breaks down your
recovery your sleep and your daily
strain into a format that's easy to
interpret and some days I wake up in the
green and this tells me that I'm ready
to go attack the day and other days I
wake up in the red and I know that I
gotta take it easy and I can look back
in time and see how I got there if
you're working to be intentional and
build healthier habits whoop can help
you get there start keeping an eye on
your health and wellness at a deeper
level go to whoop dot com that's
w-h-o-o-p.com and use promo code deloni
to get 10 off your order today
all right we're going out to Cassie in
Cambridge where they got equations on
the walls at the boss what's up Cassie
hi Dr John are you an MIT kid or a
Harvard kid a Harvard kid
no no no no
I'm not hey I'm not either I'm a state
school guy that's what I'm talking about
hey what's up Cassie all right
um so I guess my question here is
it sounds weird but I have have you ever
have you ever heard this show
yeah I have yeah I promise whatever
you're about to say you're not the weird
one so bring it on
okay
um so I I have fear
um and it's like it was strange but I
will like I'll cancel appointments and
I'll miss appointments because of it and
I don't know like I don't know if this
is
something is there something I can do
before it or if I need to deal with
something or if it's just normal I guess
why are you scared to go to the doctor
why does your body tell you we don't
need to go there
um
well I I guess I I had a bad like pretty
bad experiences in the past and tell me
about him
yeah
um so
I was in elementary school and I think
part of it is just tell me tell me tell
me
okay
um when I was in elementary school I
struggled with food and just stuff like
that and I ended up Cassie
yes
say it all the way
well I was hospitalized and then for
what for what
this is what I like I can't I can talk
about it but I can't name it so I I
don't know okay so you had a challenge
with food did you restruct with anorexia
or bulimia
uh yeah one of those yeah okay why can't
you say that
I don't know like will you say it right
now
Maybe
go for it
I struggled with some
eating issues
okay
and it led to me
being hospitalized for a couple weeks
and then I was thrown into a basically a
psych ward but
um
I just had like a really a rough
experience in there
um it was a teenage unit and I was 12 at
the time
and I was I was a good idea she was when
I was younger so I just saw like so many
different things
um
in there and it was a really I guess a
really scary scary experience
what was
um
thank you for saying that out loud by
the way I know that was hard okay
um
why were you a Goody Two Shoe
me
um
I'm an asset I'm an asset in a hard
direct way is that cool
yeah
often Goody Two-Shoes can be a trauma
response
it's a way to keep the boogeyman away
it's a way to keep a scary uncle or a
mom and dad from being on your case from
messing with you if you just do
everything perfect and toe the line and
stay out of the way
I did well in school I just wanted of
course you did I like I like to do well
yeah okay
where did the what were the roots in
disordered eating
um what was that a response to
I
I don't know I felt like I was so young
that it doesn't make sense to me okay
okay and I I've I've recently in the
past year heard some studies that
suggests that may be a
more genetic than we previously thought
we used to subscribe like prescribe it
all to traumas and anxiety response and
that there is some some significant
literature that suggests that has can be
highly genetic that there's really not a
lot of environmental factors but I don't
know enough about it
um here's what's important now are you
healed now are you are you do you have a
good relationship with food now
I would say yeah for the most part I
feel good good do you still struggle
from anorexia or bulimia
I not really only when times are tough
but okay no not really okay
times have been tough for everybody
recently Cassie
yeah so why do you need to go to the
doctor
it's
um it's kind of a regular
this year and what was it I don't
um it wasn't related well I don't know
if it was or wasn't related I they say
it wasn't but I always feel super guilty
that I caused the issue
um
what's the issue
so I I basically I had a growth in my
body
um that required
surgery but I guess I'm like this is my
kind of my fault because I waited until
the growth became massive until I went
to the doctors
um to get it checked out
I don't you and I could spend some time
together I know but
you don't like Cassie
and I don't like that you don't like
Cassie because I like Cassie
and I like I think
are Pleasant with her
but you think she does a lot of stuff
wrong
I think some she could be better in some
ways yeah
wanting to improve on things is one
thing be better is a totally different
proposition
is that fair
yeah yeah
so here's like the last couple of times
or there's been a couple of times in
your life that you've gone to the doctor
one of them has ended in a surgery that
you have shame over
another time ended up in a
hospitalization and you probably heard
it from your parents about how expensive
it was and how they had one of meant to
quit their job and they had to right it
caused a major
um
upheaval in your home that somehow was
transferred onto you this is your fault
not we're your parents and we love you
and it's our job to take care of you to
the ends of the Earth that's what we
signed up for when we had you
but
if you'd you're fine just eat or just
just like write those kind of things
and here you are now
and
you need to go to the doctor
and your body's put some GPS pins in the
doctor's offices as though they are the
problem
and I'd love to reframe that and say no
um you had some scary experiences as a
kid and it probably wasn't a good idea
for you it wasn't a good idea for a 12
year old that we put on the
on a psych ward with teenagers
the number of students over the years
that I I sat with in psych wards that
were like Oh I thought I wasn't okay but
whoa after spending two nights in a side
Court they're like I'm fine right I
don't have that
um is I mean all but like a handful had
that experience and I can only imagine
how terrifying that was for a 12 year
old
right
the phobia is Real This fear is real and
there is one way to heal from it
and it's to go right through it
okay and I know that's the worst
possible answer you can get
here's um what I have found in my life
um
is you have to teach your body that it's
okay to go now it wasn't then it's okay
now
that's what healing from trauma is I can
walk in and I can feel my heart rate
getting up I can feel my hands I can
feel myself picking up my phone to
cancel and I'm not going to I'm gonna
feel it and what we're going to do over
the course of a few
um visits is we're going to retrain our
body that doctors are trustworthy and
they're okay
and then if I do have to have surgery
thank goodness there's a group of people
who's dedicated their lives to keeping
people like me safe
right it's a total reframe from oh God
if I go there they're going to cut
another big lump of my body out of me
it's man thank goodness they are are
keeping me safe and I'm gonna feel it
and I'm gonna feel it and I'm gonna feel
it and here's the other thing
disorder eating has a way of isolating
us creating a space between us and
relationships and us and the rest of the
world fair
yeah
and I've struggled with disordered
eating almost my entire life
okay and I only recently started talking
about that publicly it's been a mess
okay I tell you that to tell you I can
be in a crowded room completely by
myself because I am so preoccupied with
judging how I look and how I'm standing
and how I'm moving right yeah okay the
only way through that is to open up to
other people
and now I come out of my room and I look
at my wife and say is this shirt okay to
wear and she says yes
and
I let I trust her more than my feelings
and I'm learning I'm in the process
right now in my 40s of learning
how to trust and how to feel what a
shirt feels like that fits it doesn't
feel awkward that you know what I mean
that's where you are and we're gonna
practice
practice relationships so I have found
walking through anxiety walking through
phobias walking through those moments
I can only do it with somebody else with
me by my side
okay and so it's making an appointment
to go to the doctor and calling a friend
and saying I need you to come here and
um set up an appointment for me or I
need you to call and make an appointment
for me on the first two or three while
I'm learning and that way I can't call
and cancel them only you can and then I
need you to come pick me up because I'm
not going to get in the car
is actually a good idea here's what
we're doing we're owning reality and
reality is right now
um I can't stop eating sugar I'm just
throwing that out there so I'm gonna
take all the sugar out of my house
I can't right now and you can but it
feels like you can't
I can't make a good choice when it comes
to seeing a doctor because every time I
make an appointment my whole body
freezes on me and tenses up because the
last few times I've gone it's been a
disaster
both financially and physically
so hey I need you to make this
appointment for me or do it with me and
then I need you to drive me would you
come pick me up would you walk alongside
me during this during this time would
you be in the in the room with me would
you sitting there with me
um well the doctor gives me the news
um I'd really appreciate that and then
our bodies are going to see that we are
not alone our bodies are going to see
that that doctor's got our best interest
at heart our body's going to see that
we're more well after we visit our
doctor than before
and then it's going to learn over time
oh Cassie's driving now Cassie's in
control
doctors aren't the end of the world I
had a bad experience a real bad
experience once and they saved my life
the next time
they're forming out against me and we're
just teaching our body that
Your brave brave young woman I would
also recommend find a local counselor in
your area and let them know I really
struggle with some historical trauma
here I don't know where it's from I
don't know why
um still struggle with disorder eating
every once in a while
when things get stressed and things are
always stressed
and I want some practical tips on
breathing through and box breathing and
dropping my shoulders when I've got to
do hard things like make doctor's
appointments and actually show up make
counseling appointments and actually
show up
we can't do Life by ourselves Cassie we
can't gotta have other people
professionals and Friends
moms and dads and romantic Partners we
need everybody
we'll be right back
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships I'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to John deloney.com to
take the next step towards Wellness
that's own your past change your future
at John deloney.com
all right we're back as we wrap up
today's show hey um don't forget the
brand new questions for humans cards are
out get online and go get those save
your holiday season
spark some romance reconnect with your
kids or your adult parents your aging
parents the tools are for you
today's song of the day is a shout out
to all these Seattle callers from one of
the OG's the Stone Temple Pilots and
songs called the interstate love song
goes like this waiting on a Sunday
afternoon for what I've read between the
lines your lies feeling like a hand in
rusted chains so do you laugh at those
who cry reply leaving on a southern
train only yesterday you lied Promises
of what I seem to be only watch the time
go by all of these things you said to me
you live
goodbye
goodbye
[Music]